are you ready to live a healthier
life did you know that veterinarians
have cured over 600 major diseases and
animals with simple minerals at a cost
of only a few dollars a
day but doctors have been prescribing
costly medications to their patients for
those same problems but no one ever gets
better if you or a loved one has ever
suffered from heart disease diabetes
ADHD low energy insomnia or arthritis
listen up because this may very well be
the information you've been searching
for it is time for you to meet Dr joa
wallik creator of the world famous Dead
Doctors Don't Lie book and lecture
series Dr wallik has created a number of
life-enhancing products that include the
missing minerals your body
needs thousands of people have reported
miraculous results and are now leading a
healthy more pain-free
life don't you owe it to yourself to
find out all of the facts visit our
website to learn
more